after a historically bad week capping
off a historically bad year joe biden's
presidency is now on the ropes things
are going so poorly that even as
one-time
protectors the media mob they're now
beginning to take note look at this
headline from fake news cnn you can't
make it up quote is biden's presidency
doomed meanwhile one article from axios
titled biden's epic failures it details
the litany of biden-cause disasters both
here at home and abroad according to the
article quote it's rare for a president
to be at odds with republicans with
moderate democrats and liberal democrats
all at the same time but that's where
biden finds himself in other words
nobody likes you joe
poor joey nobody nobody thinks he's
competent either even ms dnc's top
democrat chucky todd blasting biden for
failing to change the tone in the
country bring people together after a
speech last week former president trump
in arizona
this is funny he said that biden was
more destructive than five presidents
combined now a new cbs poll shows that
50 percent of americans are frustrated
with biden's presidency only 25 percent
are satisfied you know it takes an awful
lot of failure to get 75 percent of the
country
not loving what you're doing and fully
50 percent of the country frustrated at
what you are doing look at this graph
from gallup in just one year biden
managed to flip america's party
identification average look at this a
nine-point democratic advantage to a
five-point gop advantage the best
numbers for the republican party since
1995. donald trump runs again just needs
one bumper sticker
maybe a few rallies and all needs to say
is miss me yet anyway and when they won
in 1995 that was when the republicans
had been in exile out of power for 40
years now one reason for joe's
difficulties he rarely works a full week
even a full day it's clear he's not up
to the job because of his cognitive
decline that is getting worse he is weak
he is frail on most days he didn't even
start work till around 10 a.m typically
calls a lid between one and four in the
afternoon he averages less than one
public event a day and of course you'll
almost never see the leader of the free
world working at the white house on a
weekend he's almost always in delaware
presumably taking lots of naps in fact
during his first year biden spent more
than a quarter of his time in delaware
now during the week of christmas
remember when kovan 19 was surging to
record highs we didn't have tests
available therapeutics ran out
anti-virals hadn't been manufactured joe
is nowhere to be found and today while
most americans were celebrating the
amazing life of dr martin luther king jr
joe biden m.i.a again he was once again
enjoying a three-day weekend in delaware
and could not be bothered they need to
really rest him this week because we're
going to get a presser out of him
and he had fewer
press conferences than the last six
presidents anyway in his first year we
did however hear from vice president
kamala harris she used today's holiday
to trash americans calling them
complicit because the democrats
so-called voting rights bill is now
pretty much doa take a look
last week the president and i
visited atlanta to deliver a message
it is time for the united states senate
to do its job
a landmark bill as we all know
sits before the united states senate the
freedom to vote john our lewis act
as dr king said
the only normalcy he would accept is the
normalcy that recognizes the dignity and
worth of all god's children
today we must not be
complacent
or complicit
working with praising joe biden wasn't
that long ago kamala harris was ripping
joe biden of shreds accusing him of
being complicit during a primary debate
perhaps she forgot her own words we'll
remind her to hear you talk about the
reputations
of two united states senators who built
their reputations
and career on the segregation of race in
this country
and it was not only that but
you also worked with them to oppose
busing
and
you know there was a little girl in
california
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools and she was
bussed to school every day
and that little girl was me
wow now he was she was talking about
when joe partnered with the former
klansmen robert kkk bird to stop the
integration of public schools you see
joe even said publicly he didn't want uh
public schools to become oh what was the
word uh racial jungles that's right his
words of course kamala harris isn't the
only democrat to shamefully exploit race
to push a political agenda it's used
every election it used to be every two
years every four years every election
cycle democrats accuse their political
enemies same playbook they're racist
they're sexist they're homophobic
xenophobic islamophobic now transphobic
they want dirty air water and they want
to take us back to the days of jim crow
and of course they want to throw grandma
and grandpa in a wheelchair off a cliff
today nancy pelosi said mlk thomas
jefferson george washington and abe
lincoln would all have tears in their
eyes
if they knew republicans and two
democrats for preserving the filibuster
you can't make it up take a look
if you really truly
want to honor dr king
don't dishonor him by using a
congressional custom as an excuse for
protecting our democracy he has a
monument on the mall along with abraham
lincoln
george washington
thomas jefferson
all of them
with tears in their eyes
for the departure from our democracy
that is happening right now unless
the truth is acknowledged
and this legislation is passed
if you think nancy pelosi's theatrics
were over the top many other top
democrats they were worse some openly
accusing their fellow democrats that
would be christian cinema joe manchin
now they're calling the fellow democrats
racist and bigoted take a look
people like joe manchin and christian
cinema these are the white people that
martin luther king jr warned us about i
submit that members of the senate
regardless of their party
no longer have to ask what we would have
done then
we're doing whatever we would have done
then right now
this is a moral moment
uh this is a 1965 moment they have sent
this signal they have been very clear
about it they don't care about
minorities they don't care about blacks
they don't care about people in their
own districts who are there going to
deny their voting rights and undermine
their voting rights i know uh robert
byrd the former senator the late senator
i know what he did in the latter part of
his life yes he was a member of the ku
klux klan but in the latter part of his
life he changed so what i would say to
you is that it is hurting people
the filibuster is hurting people
not to be outdone hillary clinton now
trying desperately to regain relevancy
inserted herself into the conversation
using an mlk quote to trash cinema and
mansion i had hoped that white moderates
would understand that law and order
exist for the purpose of establishing
justice and that when they fail in this
purpose they become the uh the
dangerously structured structured dams
that block the flow of social progress
by the way hillary where were you in the
summer of 2020 we could have used your
help anyway quite a turnaround from the
woman that once referenced african
americans as super predators hillary is
so desperate to be relevant kind of sad
recently democratic strategist james
carville i actually know james like
james have debated james he's not a dumb
guy anyway he had advice for his fellow
liberals quote you democrats my fellow
democrats you whine too much quit being
a whiny party that's an understatement
unfortunately i seriously doubt they
will take his advice hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else